vu de l'extérieur cela ressemble à une
fabrique de meubles
l'enseigne plutôt discrète mais le
directeur n'oublie jamais de vanter la
qualité de sa matière première on
réflexion'' les grumes qui viennent
essentiellement des approches et puis
pour locales à 60 kilomètres autour de
la ronde dans les forêts voisines dans
les ateliers on découvre très vite la
spécialité du site au gf les six
recueils avec les usines de reyrieux
dans l'ain le site de jus s'est produit
près de 145 mille cercueil par an c'est
le leader du secteur en europe et fait
entrer dans le rang en gardant les
cercueils à pour noter des boîtes c'est
comme un meuble à toutes les salariées
dont l'habitude et ils font des caisses
toute la journée on prend tonnes loin
dans un cercueil que dans un meuble pour
protéger le personnel et préserver la
production
on a bien sûr ici repenser les méthodes
de travail
cent vingt personnes sont employées dans
cette usine
tous les salariés ont conscience qu'ils
jouent un rôle important
bien sûr tout le monde se sont utiles
pour un peu plus que ça tout le monde
est touché par ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans le monde
contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait
croire la production n'a pas doublé ou
triplé
elle a légèrement augmenté on s'est
organisé pour produire à peu près 10 à
15% production de plus par jour on a
privilégié certains modèles les modèles
les plus vendus aux familles
ça nous permet de produire un petit peu
plus de leurs deux passions à 420
certain que tous les cercueils fabriqués
dans cette usine sont destinés au marché
français et à jussey on l'a sur il n'y a
aucun risque de pénurie pour ce produit
si particulier